i'm going to open the subcommittee
session on senate bill 397 in reference
to
the mental health counseling compact
that will be the only part that we'll be
working on the amendment
to this bill is going to be done in a
separate subcommittee hearing as it is
as it is a kind of a different topic
here so
just as a reminder to everyone this is
relative the mental health counseling
compact
and
we did have a public hearing on this
already
we we did entertain several questions in
reference to the processing of this and
how it works
in my notes um
this would re to freshen everybody back
up this would require 10 states
in order for this compact to take effect
maine maryland alabama louisiana
colorado have already enacted this there
are 15 other states considering this
compact as well
the only other new england state
we had a standard series of questions
in reference to discipline
as to which
if someone
commits an act or or there's a problem
how is that handled we went over that as
to
who gets
primary jurisdiction there
we were informed the
and the board of mental health is well
so i
today have representative woods with us
from health and human services who is
quite familiar with
health compacts so i asked him to be on
this
subcommittee as this is a
bill that
involves
health and human services really
so with that
i will
entertain any concerns or questions
anybody has in reference to this
uh mr chairman i would just like to say
that as the vice chairman of the
telehealth commission we've discussed
this at the telehealth commission as
well
and it would certainly make our life a
lot easier in resolving interstate
excellent
thank you and the other question that
was brought up that i brought up that we
seem to have a little bit difficulty in
in getting processed was
you know this is a this is a
transitional piece of legislation as we
are going to be leaving a compact and
entering into a different compact
and in reference to the processing of
that do
and for those of you that are familiar
with
well computer programming some other
things this is kind of an if then
scenario whereas we are not going to put
ourselves on the state of new hampshire
in limbo exiting a compact without
entering into a reformed or new compact
that so there's that's not going to
cause new hampshire to become an island
in the sense that
we've now we've now just
so we didn't looking through my notes we
anything in the way of objections i
don't recall any testimony to the
contrary that was
uh in in general um in favor of compacts
like this that
make licensing issues easier and provide
services
a problem and a serious objection though
to this particular compact the problem
is is there's a difference
between
interstate
compacts um
well let me put it this way
figuratively speaking you can't talk
somebody down off a building
on the phone
sure so there's a lot of things that you
can do
but i'm i'm not sure this is one of them
i've um like education i
am a firm believer that face to face is
very important for this particular
practice
but then there's
something in here that's a red flag to
me
that if it stays
i cannot and will not support this bill
and that is if you look at
the bottom of page
two
under
roman numeral one
to participate in the compact estate
most currently
the first few things make sense license
and regulate licensed professional
counselors require licenses to pass
nationally recognized
blah blah blah require licenses so on
and so forth
orientation and ethical
practice and and then we get to number
two
well under c it's requiring licensees to
have a 60 semester hour 90 quarter
hour master's degree and so on and so
forth right so help me out here because
i don't see that on my you're looking at
um you'll need the printer on page four
to give page in line okay okay thank you
on this it's saying page two but it's
oh i see okay so on page four line two
part c
the requirement for 60 semester hour and
night right and the first few make
perfect sense to me
um or most of them make perfect sense to
me
then you get to training in social and
cultural
diversity i cannot will not accept this
premise any longer i cannot and will not
support
any bill
that has this type of terminology in it
and it's it's
it's a poison pill really because then
further down it it makes a very
under other circumstances very
reasonable
uh requirement under number nine in
parentheses it says other areas is
determined by the commission and that
would be
fine it's understandable that they need
the flexibility
to add or take out
training requirements
except that i know
i know
it's not misinformation or
disinformation or conspiracy theorism
i know
that
that leaves the way wide open
for somebody to say okay we'll take out
social and cultural diversity and we'll
leave in number nine and that means
social and cultural diversity goes back
in
under another name
i've had it with social and cultural
diversity proclamations cannot and will
not support it
sorry about that i really am
okay so
is
i think relevant in this world
the fact that folks
that have a
social work differently
and
i think that that
that element of that is something that
is
well integrated into the profession
already
um
you know and i don't and i don't
i don't look at this as that i
i don't look at this in the sense of
them trying to manipulate that i think
it's it's just a matter of
there are some cultures that just handle
this type of thing
differently and
that's something that's going to
exist
in in all aspects of this
it pro i would imagine it probably does
in the current compact
so
that i mean if that's if that is the
ultimate poison pill for you to
agree to enter into this compact then
i think that you're there's almost no
way around that in this in the mental
health profession
at all
because we can't the state of new
hampshire
can't
pull that out
to enter into the compact it's a go or
no-go scenario this is the details of
that compact but it would it's a matter
of do we accept
the conditions set forth in the compact
for the state of new hampshire or not as
a as a mass so representative woods jump
in with their certainly as a someone
who's extraordinarily familiar with
these well i i completely understand and
appreciate
the difficulty that which uh you
mentioned however uh
this is part
for those who don't know where both of
us are physicians and i'm uh
was new hampshire's delegate to the ama
and listened to and served on uh council
on science and public health
uh but part of that debate was cultural
diversity awareness
for the physician that's embedded in our
code of ethics which is how physicians
are
judged
i'm not talking about the other
ancillary nurses and so forth
but embedded in there is
awareness of cultural diversity and
that's impaired in our essay that we
have to follow the american code of
ethics
and by that has meant awareness of
sometimes simple things like being aware
of getting an appointment and realizing
that that may be a major holiday for an
individual
uh that say muslim and it's ramadan
or being aware that under some
circumstances
uh that a a teenage girl even though she
may be 16 or 17 can't have an
appointment
under some circumstances
even for a ch i was a hand surgeon
checking out a hand problem without her
father being there and being aware of
that so
that is
uh i appreciate what you're saying but i
think
uh
again i'm reading how they meant this
but
that's uh
the kind of thing that we as physicians
and i think that would apply here that
that's meant to be aware of
that so you can better communicate with
that particular individual
uh on a one-to-one and a personal basis
but
just to reiterate again the way the
compacts work is
uh you can't change them uh you it it's
it's all or none uh
so but having said that uh and i don't
um
part of this was not the enabling um
piece that goes with this
and by what i mean by that there is an
enabling uh um
you know what you want to call it a
piece of legislation shall we say that
the the compact organizers put out
and in it uh it states as soon as x
number of people in this case 10
that it goes into effect
now the first i forgot usually is five
or six or whatever
once that has been formulated then rules
can be uh promulgated
and the first five six or seven are
at the table and then can look at rules
and make those changes so if you're
say
they say the first seven
that join will be part of this
review committee and that then takes
place
and some small issues can be addressed
and they need to be addressed
an example is if you look
uh at page and this i see stuck over
from when we considered it i forgot it
was two years ago
um at least on on the uh uh
397 as amended on page two
line 37 it says home state
means the member state that is the
licensee's private primary state of
residence well that should be the
primary state of practice
because and again example is i live in
vermont
but i just cross the river and i
practice
at dartmouth hitchcock sure so what you
want is so
this really creates a bit and it was it
was pointed out back i forgot when that
was now but that line is still in there
so those are the kinds of things
that this rules committee has the
ability to address if you're the first
and again i'd i haven't i've not been
privy to the enabling
um
piece that goes along parallel with this
and you may have that which i don't
so there's a number of factors um since
i'm
talking
uh this
com the concept of compact is part of a
national effort uh to make uniform
standards
um and this is uh evolution uh in terms
of standards uh my great-grandfather uh
was a self-taught horseback doctor out
in the plains of texas
uh he didn't have to have a board of
medicine anything he just you know i'm
here i'm i'm the doc i'm and we've
progressed along
um and
this came through such that uh finally
we come uh for specialty training uh for
physicians we have the american board of
medical specialties
uh such that there's 26 specialties that
are recognized and that avoids a lot of
quotes certifying agencies
like when i chaired the workers comp
advisory council we looked at people who
could do ime their independent medical
evaluations
well turns out if you were certified to
do that you could do them
well turns out there's 400 at that time
there was 450 or so
certifying
agencies 130 of them in las vegas
so that tells you a little bit what they
were certified
uh so i got a piece of legislation
passed
i wasn't in the legislature at the time
but as a chair of the workers comp
council to say that in fact to do this
particular
ime or independent medical evaluation
you had to be
board certified by the one of the 26
american board of medical specialties
and that gives you a national standard
because these are national tests i did
orthopedics
and everybody in their specialty passes
boards that gives a standard
okay
uh looking at that particular issue i
was
ultimately sued as a matter of fact
because someone who was doing imes
didn't have wasn't board certified and
that aeg's uh got office got involved
and
he said we'll take care of it so i got
off the hook
but there's been this
ongoing from my great grandfather doing
it on his home american board of medical
specialties
to provide national
licensure so a national standard to make
it so that as a physician i can move
from state to state as a patient
you can continue your care
on a on a standard basis and i think
that's critically important
and uh the fsmb or the americans
the federation of state medical boards
has been advocating for national
licenses i'll uh
this is an example of a type of
national licensing
uh for as long as i've been associated
with them for 30 some odd years
so i view this as a as a progression
uh from my great-grandfather through all
the certifying agencies in las vegas to
a national standard
uh to enhance uh a patient care
and in fact i was up until recently also
on the telemedicine commission
uh and we heard testimony where in fact
one of the biggest uses was
mental health
and it made a huge i mean we're talking
big big time impact and the follow-up
data shows
that there was it was uh efficacious
in that particular setting
uh and in fact there was a significant
i've forgotten the numbers but
significant numbers that preferred
rather than having to come in
uh not that they didn't but
so
i think it's that progression of our use
of technology it'll finally sort itself
out how it's used just like a new drug
as soon as the drug hits the market boys
the use goes
off the charts
then it drops down and people and then
it stabilizes
we're doing the same thing with
telehealth it's a technology that is
just
asking to be used and i often say that
medicine's often on the dull edge
of technology
but in this in a situation
uh medicine is really responding and
making good use of it so i'll stop sorry
uh going on but that's uh a few extra
comments uh on sidebars as well to to
piggyback a little bit
i sit on the ptsd commission and there
are
people that specialize in that type of
thing
and in new hampshire
i think we have
for first responders we have like two
for the entire state and that the
commission found out in a hurry
that without
reaching out across new hampshire's
borders
we got a problem and
this this is certainly an area where
people specialize
in some cases the military has folks
that have specialized for years and that
that's really more military related
but there are certain aspects of mental
health where there are folks that focus
on certain aspects in new hampshire as
we all know is a relatively tiny state
so
in those cases folks may
what they what is most cost effective
and most productive for them
as far as treatment may really rely or
require them to to
branch out into some other locations and
i think that's what
ultimately the current compact is
attempting to do and certainly this one
will do as well so
that's just an example of how
we can't necessarily handle this
in-house
representative marsh
yes thank you mr chair i just wanted to
add a couple things to what
representative woods just said uh first
of all i just checked the website of the
mental health counseling compact it goes
into effect when 10 states have adopted
it and according to their website right
now nine states have adopted so
if new hampshire adopts this it goes
into effect we don't need to worry about
contingencies um the the second thing
regards to the efficacy
of telehealth in addressing
various behavioral health issues and in
fact to do counseling we've heard a
substantial amount of data
which has been collected by the federal
government on to that effect
at the telehealth commission
they have postponed making a final
decision about parity
and audio only because they're still
collecting data and i recognize that but
one of the things that has come out in
the commission is that
telehealth in this circumstance is is
extraordinarily effective and in many
ways more effective than in office
visits because the practitioner
through the medium of telehealth is
brought into the home of the person
being counseled they can see what
conditions they live in they can see
what other issues that they're dealing
with and and they also have a uh
essentially 100 um show rate uh so you
don't have people not showing up for
appointments and that has made the
service hugely more effective and it's
made this actually a preferred modality
uh for people practicing this kind of of
a medicine so i i i think that we need
to recognize that that's what the actual
so along with that too the the other
thing is
you know from a licensing standpoint
right we've
in this committee
for quite a while have tried to figure
out ways to
in a lot of the cases of licensing in
we've had discussions in here about you
know reciprocation versus recognition
versus
compacts you know versus
you know
because those are all obviously
different avenues as far as
you know is my license that i have in
vermont recognized is it an equivalent
do i have to get a different one and you
know we've gone back and forth on
several bills this this term in
reference to that from everything from
mental health to hairdressers frankly um
so
you know this is one of the things that
i think is appealing
in the sense that
it doesn't require the state of new
open
up this one i don't this would probably
not fall under well plc is okay with it
so i guess maybe this would be going to
them but they're not gonna have to add
staff they're not gonna you know what
i'm saying because we're in the compact
now it's just recognized
you see what i'm saying so
that's that's just the i know this is a
you know this thing's 20 30 something
pages long and
and the reality of it is is it's it's
the details of of what's being presented
before us
in the sense of
you know it advise it's more advisory i
mean we can't like i said we can't we
can't amend this we can't pick it apart
we're either doing it or not and
and um
you know i think that
it's not perfect there's no doubt i mean
there's
but at least
i mean you know you have so a lot of
these compacts have incentives
to be to get in early right because you
have rule making councils and things
like that if you get in the door early
you get it your seat at the table's a
little bit bigger
and
you know that's
it's interesting that you know i mean
things are moving along when we had the
public hearing there were only five
states that enacted i mean we're at nine
so clearly other legislative bodies are
are going through their motions of
processing this and
um
you know this sounds like
this sounds like it's going to happen so
this thing this thing is going to exist
one of the questions that was not asked
and i didn't think of it really till now
is the is the
the now nine states that are just
waiting on a tenth state
i would presume are going to exit
whatever existing compacts they have to
get into this now we we don't have
representatives from other states here
to answer that but the current compact
that we're in what happens if half the
states that
that are in the current compact now
leave to join this one
the compact that we and we don't the
compact that we're now involved in is
now smaller less effective
and and probably chaotic in the in the
sense that it you know you've got
you've got act you know members of
it could be could be members of the
rulemaking part or the upper part of the
administration of that that have exited
so
um i didn't think to ask that at the
time
yeah generally when a state leaves one
contract and joins another they would do
the same thing that we're doing in the
second half of this bill where when the
contingency is met uh it's a repeal and
replace and it replaces no i get that
but what i'm saying is is that if if
because we're in a current compact so if
we're in a compact that's currently with
15 states and nine of those states leave
the compact and enter this new one
now we're in a compact we're not a
compact in 15 states anymore we're in a
compact with six
and now you're talking about
the efficiency of the compact that you
are having
i'm not sure that we're in a mental
health counseling compact at this point
in time because this bill is written to
make this a new chapter as opposed to or
feeling replaced okay because there was
so this am i confusing this then with a
different color yes the second half of
this is a compact which is repeal and
replace that's what it is all right so
that's the part we're not talking about
today gotcha
all right
you see my point though not applicable
here we'll deal with that monday but
um
so yeah so i guess we have nothing
if we that's right if we have nothing on
the mental health side then
which is why we have such a shortage of
mental health professionals in the state
of new hampshire
and like i said the ptsd commission was
was specifically addressing that
um in reference to the that field the
in
what the bill the ptsd bill that came
out really doesn't doesn't address that
because it's waiting on this
so
so the commission the ptsd commission is
waiting to figure out what we do with
this because now
at least in their world this opens it up
to 10 states
and potentially someone that could now
decide to specialize
because now they're gonna have a client
base that's that's large enough to do so
so one of the issues we have in the
north country is that the counselors who
provide this kind of service don't
choose to live in that kind of
environment
so prior to the advent of telehealth
most of these services were basically
unavailable up where i live um and the
this
the availability of these services
through telehealth has hugely increased
the availability of this kind of service
to my constituents
just to
feed on that as well
the reason one of the reasons it's
really
been so well utilized
let's say that your mother dies in san
antonio
and you go down there and there's a real
all kinds of issues and you're beginning
to fall apart you can now call
also if you're in the north country
and you you're trying to get a job and
it takes two hours to get to the office
your employer really doesn't like you
taking the day off
once a week or once every two or one
whatever it happens to be
you can do it on your lunch hour sure
uh so
you you you get
much higher participation
very lower much lower dropout
employers really like it because their
employees are healthier
and also letting them to even take a day
an hour off in the middle of the
afternoon shall we say
they can do that easily
in the most instances and that gives
a nice
uh expression of concern to the patient
as well that yeah i'm an employer but
yeah go ahead take take an hour and they
don't have to take the day off
so there's many other watersheds that
come when this is put in place
so i guess the other thing that i'm i'm
just thinking in reference mark to your
your concerns is that
realistically
as you're aware with most compacts
they're fluid right so
they're fluid in the sense that there
are compacts that the state of new
hampshire has entered into that
that you know when these when these
boards meet can make changes and
modifications and really i mean new
hampshire has a seat at the table and we
can object and
and or or support whatever is going on
and then ultimately if a compact becomes
such that
the state of new hampshire finds it
unacceptable our option is to leave i
mean that's
that's really what exists so
um and again i'm referring again you
mentioned it changing things uh and
again
it's not here and you may have them but
uh the uh promulgating documents
um and those are the rules by which
things can be changed and the committee
when the full committee wants to make
they may want to know well how you know
what are we restricted in
if we do join
what kind of restrictions are
are there placed
and they may want to have those
promulgating
papers in hand um i i didn't bring i
didn't uh
i didn't actually look for them from our
our previous because we had them
available
and there be maybe some questions uh
arises how you you know how can things
be modified and how hard or easy it is
and we and we've done that i mean we did
this we did it last year that we pulled
out of an interstate compact because it
just wasn't
it just wasn't functioning for this for
us at all so so the state you know we
the legislature has done it and they
will do it if it's necessary we've
clearly shown that so
you know i
the amendment terms are on page 18 lines
31-33
the compact committee
by the member states and no amendment
becomes effective until it's ratified
into the laws of all the member states
so
that's the first one the second one
starts starts on page 19.
so i you know i think that that's kind
of just where
where we're at here do we ultimately do
we think that the state of new hampshire
will benefit from entering into
or not and that's you know and
there's
we we didn't really other than other
than
that issue
um there really hasn't been any anybody
that's come forward
with other objections yet representative
so let me step back a moment and see um
what else can be done if there are
issues with the compact itself because
i'm reading through testimony of the
director of the oplc and there was an
emergency license for 20 20 and 21
yep that was issued
right can we work that angle instead and
so explain those licenses
so so what you're uh if i'm
understanding what you're asking me
instead of entering into a compact this
we just we have our own basically
reciprocating
well the emergency order allowed the
oplc to issue um sure the licenses
as you and i have
discussed uh our
well actually a lot of us have discussed
our displeasure with using emergency
orders for to operate anything so
um so at that point i mean
if you want to set this up in a
functional
way that is
not
under that
premise
then you're talking about either getting
into a compact or
opening the state up with inventing our
own in essence because if we if we were
to do reciprocating license agreements
with
other states we're
inventing
another wheel that already that we
already have
unfortunately the state of massachusetts
is not a participant in the compact at
this time and the vast majority of the
emergency licenses went to the
practitioners in the state of
massachusetts so we haven't solved that
problem yet the legislature in the state
of massachusetts could solve it by
adopting this contact as well as several
other compacts which the state of new
hampshire is a part of
now the other thing that i didn't see in
here
in correct me if i'm wrong but this
doesn't this doesn't
prohibit us from
from doing that if we wanted to enter
into a reciprocating agree if
massachusetts rejected this in its
entirety and just we're not doing it
this we wouldn't be prohibited from
entering into a reciprocating agreement
with the state of massachusetts
we would not there's nothing in here
that says we can't play with other
people in the sandbox once we enter this
one so
i'm i'm not sure there was something we
were reciprocating
i believe
um the oplc issued licenses to those who
were licensed in other states
no matter what their home state was
doing to us
but by entering into the compact right
yeah i don't i don't see that in the
testimony no compact has been discussed
here
um
lindsey courtney's testimony
well
the opl in specific reference to 397 in
my notes i have that
oplc um
was on board with this
with this bill yes yes so i'm talking of
a different way which is what they did
during the last two years right yeah and
we're going to have i think we're going
to be duking it out over that on on
monday when we execute as far as so
you're talking about making that the
model rather than yeah yeah so we're in
charge
because it worked so well in 2021
and brought in so many psychologists and
family therapists and
mental health counselors and they're on
the numbers here in the testimony
yeah so you know an approach like that
it would be interesting just to hear the
opinions of the oplc director in
reference to the state of new hampshire
creating in essence its own compact
versus getting involved in an existing
one i think that that's
creating your own compact is going to
require
that that you just still throw that down
on paper you're talking about you're
going to have to have people to manage
that you're going to have to have
that that's
what we can ask them what they did for
the last two years so they were quite
successful it seems like
well and
maybe yeah we would have to ask her if
if she agrees that she was quite
successful do you have anything today
representative
uh i just want to say it i recall
hearing uh during testimony that the
statement was made that basically
massachusetts does not join compacts
and they are obviously the
how shall i say money state of northern
new england
i think they feel like they can call
their own shots
i'm not sure that new hampshire has that
much i'll point out that they did
introduce the physician licensing
compact in march so that may change
oh
yeah in in i mean it's not a big secret
right folks in new hampshire that need
to see
higher level some higher level medical
care and specialty work go to boston
it's not a secret boston is a
substantial worldwide hub for medicine
and
you know we discussed that
in the the other hearing about
you know cross-border
i mean my stepmother's a physician on a
border town in new hampshire
you know she she has privileges in both
states because the a lot of her
folks in her practice go to the hail in
hospital in haverhill so
i mean there are some things in place
right now but that's more she's a
physician she's not a mental health
practitioner
oh yeah just addressing the issue i i
think if a
lplc was able to
really have a good program and be very
nimble and responsive is one thing but i
think the hearings as they you may
recall is that was one of the real
hang-ups they can't be unless you have
you know 10 more ftes and the reason we
can't get people to participate
across borders and get a secondary
license is it takes forever right
to do that uh and as a consequence we
lose that nimbleness especially when uh
well and also reimbursement issues come
into play too for sure right that's
another issue but so i think as a
committee we i we're obviously gonna
when we
when we get into executive session we're
gonna we're gonna be duking it out over
over
both both concepts and i think that
at least in my mind having oplc in the
state of new hampshire start getting
into the compact creation business
is is beyond
the intention i think of what we were
trying to do we were trying to shrink
shrink government by creating the oplc i
don't see it as a compact model i see
i think michael is proposing
um
just licensing people from out of state
what's more nimble than that
you got a license in your state you can
practice in our state yeah i mean if
you're talking about full like
reciprocation
exactly what they did in the last two
years yeah for the last two years yeah
just yep
just making it permanent yeah i think
that's a discussion that we'll have to
uh that we'll have to have with the full
committee certainly
and that would i think that's going to
require we invite
little plc back here to
talk to them about what that
the what that would realistically look
like
because i i don't know exactly what that
would realistically look like but they
would be the ones that's the agency that
would manage it if it existed so
um
and they've already done so
yeah they would know exactly what we're
talking about they would know exactly so
that i mean
that's a that's a that's a significant
certainly a paul of a legitimate policy
but
other than that i think that you know
that's that's kind of where we are with
this type with this type of bill you
know we're not
unlike other bills you know we're not
getting until you know page 15 and
trying to strike out a line or anything
this is just the recipe for the brownies
that we're either going to eat or not
eat
and
um
and i guess you know we'll
we'll duke it out so
as far as the technical aspects of a
subcommittee
um
i mean subcommittees technically
can make recommendations i i would think
that
the recommendation at this point would
be to discuss the the really the two
the two options
the two models at at the full committee
and not necessarily decide whether you
know the subcommittee is going to vote
yes or no on this particular piece of
legislation because i think that
if we're gonna if we're gonna come up
with two concepts
then we need to discuss them both at
we're gonna continue to remain an island
and i think that's a problem we can't
continue to remain an island agreed i i
just like to say you know i'm really
sorry that i'm
being a stick in the mud on this
but here's the truth of the matter
everybody in this room knows that no
rules committee is going to modify
that item
uh
it's it's a political
pill
that's embedded in there
and no rules committee is going to
change that a rules committee rightfully
and hopefully
will change rules that actually make the
compact work better technically and
medically
um
so if this were an issue of of a
technical issue
wouldn't even arisen have arisen in my
mind
because i know it can be fixed
uh
i still remain unconvinced about the
relative value of
telemedicine for
psychological counseling
i too have a little bit of experience
in medical research
interpreting it reviewing it analyzing
it
and i'm underwhelmed
by what i've seen over the past 35 years
and i'm also quite cognizant
that if you ask a
a podiatrist
if uh
you know everybody should see a
podiatrist every 48 hours
well they'd say yes
okay and there's research to support it
so
um
with all due respect i'm not convinced
that um
telemedicine
for for this kind of thing is
is um the best choice
and number two i just know
that this political pill will not be
corrected
and
uh thanks to
rep yakubovich here
he's given us
another
i think very good model to consider
so we can still fix the problem
be happy to hear any other you know
i i i think i
i tried to understand what your point of
view
uh but i think it's it's uh as just to
reiterate
i think it's there such that as as the
ama wants physicians to be aware of
cultural differences and i think that is
crucially important
and i think it was met with that intent
i
again maybe i'm giving credit where
credit is due perhaps i'm not sure
i wasn't there at the promulgation of it
but
i would say that
erroring on the side of
whatever
that the intent was not
a political statement
by having that included and i think it
was included and
uh it would be included in anything that
uh
as a physician
uh i would i would actually expect it to
be included
and if it were not i would be very
surprised and dismayed
if it were not included because as our
society becomes more diverse
we need to be responsive and
appreciative
of those differences
and if we can do that it gives us better
understanding
for people that have a different
background and have and sometimes
those backgrounds have created part of
the problem that brings them to our
attention
and that's part of that understanding
so in that sense um again
i will admit uh there could be wrong but
i don't think the intent at all was
political i can see where if one were to
choose could make that interpretation
but my interpretation it again comes
from having served with the ama and
knowing what we're required to do
and the understanding we're supposed to
bring to the table when we see a patient
and
understand that patient in all their
dimensions
thank you thank you thank you guys for
coming here gorgeous day
last place any of us want to be i
believe me i uh
so
um okay you know i think that that's
i think that's i unless some unless
somebody really wants to to do some sort
of a formal recommendation i think that
the reality here is that the
um we we kind of have two we have two
models on how to handle this and i think
that we're just going to have to discuss
that as a full committee
um
as to what
we're not choosing between two pieces of
legislation let's not forget that right
we don't have an alternative piece of
legislation
you know whether we're going internal or
compact so let's just let's just
understand that we'll just if if 397 is
rejected by this committee
then let's just make sure that the
reasoning for that is well spelled out
so can it be handled in a
in theory bulk of this you could do that
you're talking
it would be germaine because you're
you're talking about just a structural
difference between that the topic is
still the same so i can i can see that
being germaine um but
typically
typically the folks that are going to
want to weigh in on this the folks that
have to actually deliver that are going
to want more time i mean we're not
really thrilled about the deadlines the
senate's given us on some of these
pieces of legislation to have the
director of oplc come in here and give a
go no go on on an amendment that
modifies that office
without a bit of a deep dive is not
going to probably be well received
but it you know it would be something
for the fall
you know
but all right so with that being said if
if everybody else is ready to go get
their tan on then
we'll we'll head back to the beach so
thank you thank you for coming thank
everybody
at home for watching the exciting
deliberations that have come on before
you so
godspeed